facebook ai builds crazy walking robots
baidu builds automatic excavators and
luther ai turns one
welcome to ml news
hello and welcome to ml news your
moderately regular update of what's
going on in the machine learning
world let's dive in the facebook ai blog
writes
ai now enables robots to adapt rapidly
to
changing real world conditions these are
robots that you might be
used to from things like boston dynamics
however
facebook trained those robots purely
in simulation and also end to end
while most people who make robots like
this they rely on sort of predefined
policies and then some controller that
classifies
what policy must be active at any given
point these robots are trained end to
end
meaning that the input signal is
directly converted into the force values
on the actuators that should be applied
so the cool thing
here is that this robot can adapt really
rapidly to
changing conditions in in its
environment which means that it can
handle
a number of different terrains so here
you can see the robot going off
path into grass and here you can see
that it quickly adapts to its leg being
blocked by a rock
now the interesting thing is that this
robot was never trained in the real
world this is a pure
simulation trained robot to achieve this
and to quickly adapt to different
environments facebook ai trained two
policies
one is a reinforcement learned policy
essentially
the base layer of just moving around in
different types of worlds with different
parameters
and so on in simulation by now we have a
pretty good idea of what it takes of how
we need to set up the simulations
such that things work moderately well in
the real world however to bridge the gap
to actually go into the world and deal
with problems there's a second policy
that sort of adapts to changes in the
environments
so the robot constantly predicts from
what it has done so far
what it expects the next sensor readings
to be
and if those sensor readings turn out to
be different from what it expects
it knows that the environment has
changed or is somehow different than
what it's used to and it can rapidly
adapt to that
and that's how the robot can deal with
such different
environments so safe to say these robots
are getting to the
sort of level of where they can actually
do really good things
and the potential applications of them
are
nearly endless there's a paper going
along with this
called rapid motor adaptation for a
legged robot
cis robots
that details this two strategy approach
to making the robot really adaptive and
it's by
researchers of uc berkeley carnegie
mellon and
as i said facebook ai research check out
the paper
and the blog post if you're interested
[Music]
baidu research comes up with an
autonomous excavator system for
material loading tasks so in this
article they detail the development and
research on an automatic excavator
system
now this is a pretty cool thing
apparently excavator operators are in
short supply around the world and also
the job can be dangerous sometimes
machines give us an advantage here in
that they can operate 24
7 and we can send them into maybe
dangerous maybe
toxic environments so with all of this
being pretty
cool there is a video to go along with
this and something's very strange in
that video
listen up baidu research robotics and
auto driving lab and umd
have developed an autonomous excavator
system
aes the result was published in science
robotics
this is an ai generated voice no
like how meta is this that the video
on the fully autonomous excavator system
is ai general like listen up like i
i might be super but this is a research
robotics and auto driving lab
and umd have developed an autonomous
excavator system
aes the result was published in science
robotics
the construction industry has been
booming fueled by demand for new
infrastructure
and digital transformation
[Music]
this is a robot voice nice nice uh if
this is supposed to be
like an an easter egg by baidu
researchers
well done all right next news
luther ai turns one year old
in this blog post written by connor lee
one of the
co-founders of luther ai he details
sort of the coming about of the whole
organization
of course starting with the effort to
replicate gpt-3
in the open the blog post details how
they went about it how they organized
when the various members joined
how the initial successes looked like
it's a pretty funny article
and it details more than just gpt-3
replication
such things as the pile data set which
is now publicly available
and the various successors to gpt neo be
that gpt neo x
or gpt j and also the recent
uh pushes into biology research
and ml art mostly using models
such as clip apparently this is also the
origin of the
unreal engine trick by j buster which i
reported on previously but good to see
where it actually came from the article
finishes with
a bunch of reflections by the individual
members
and also an outlook on the near
and maybe far future and of course a
bunch of memes
i totally encourage you to check out the
article it's a pretty fun and
entertaining read
okay next news the verge rights elon
musk just
now realizing that self-driving cars are
a hard
problem this after elon musk tweeted out
that the full self-driving beta is
shipping soon and that
generalized self-driving is a hard
problem as it requires
solving a large part of real world ai
didn't expect it to be so hard but the
difficulty
is obvious in retrospect nothing has
more degrees of
freedom than reality of course elon musk
is known to sort of over promise things
and then
under deliver or deliver too late but
he's also known to
actually deliver on stuff and i've done
an analysis on andre karpati's talk
on the fully self-driving system that
tesla is building up
and honestly it looks pretty cool so for
some reason
right now it's fashionable to dunk on
elon musk
which is exactly what this article does
and what the whole article
is about and of course there's all kinds
of reasons
to dunk on elon musk but for some reason
it seems to be the hip thing to do
much more than to dunk on various other
personalities and this is not lost in
the comments uh people noticed that the
coverage here
is a bit less favorable than coverages
of similar things for example by
uber but beside all of this i've noticed
something interesting
in that the slug the url of the article
which you do usually for search engine
optimization
you kind of want to condense the title
of the article
into the url such that the search
engines pick up on it
it is tesla elon musk full self-driving
admission autopilot crash
there's no crash in the title there's no
crash in the subtitle
in fact the word crash appears uh only
about
after half of the article talking about
various crashes tesla had
but you know i just found this to be
funny that it was in the url
make of that whatever you want
[Music]
next news mit technology review writes
we tested ai interview tools here's what
we found
and the subtitle is one gave our
candidate a high
score for english proficiency when she
spoke only in german
so the experiment is pretty funny in
that the candidate is supposed to
undergo some sort of an english
competency test
and when she did it regularly she
received an 8.5 out of nine
and then she did it a second time and
just read the german wikipedia entry for
psychometrics
and the system awarded her a six out of
nine
for english competency now of course the
funny thing is that
the machine gives a relatively high
score
for not even speaking the correct
language safe to say
the message one should get from this
experiment is we have a long way to go
when it comes to deploying these systems
really
there should be checks to see whether
the candidate actually speaks
english about the topic they're asked to
and so on and so on
what this is not really is an effective
criticism of the model
itself the article even says she
completed the interview again
and received the same score so at least
the system is
moderately reliable giving the same
output when you give the same input we
all can see that these systems aren't
perfect yet
and there are other studies that show
that
the background you have during an
interview whether you wear glasses or
not and so on
can all skew these automatic systems to
one direction or
another and there are also big questions
with respect to where the data is
sampled from that goes into these
systems and of course
you wouldn't dare to use the horrible
horrible horrible biased
l2 l1 whatever loss all the losses are
problematic apparently
so the article tested multiple systems
and all the systems
gave essentially a response whenever
the interviewee was doing german instead
of english trick now again is this
a problem with the model itself probably
not because the model
was mostly trained to distinguish better
english or more standard english
whatever you want to do out of that
from less standard or less desired
english
whatever that means model was not
designed to distinguish
not english at all and i think the thing
to take away from this is that
if you deploy these systems in the real
world especially
if they work on human inputs if they
deal with humans if they have some
decision power or some input into
decision power
it is important to think of the outliers
the edge cases the out of distributions
things that could come into the model
that you didn't necessarily
intended and to build in some safety
measures to have some sanity checks here
and there
and in the future i hope we're able to
find a way to take the best of what
these ai systems have to offer
and infuse just a little bit of the
human process
back into them all right
next news runwayml releases sql which is
a video editor
which is one in the browser which is
already pretty cool but two has a lot of
built-in ai
tools so right now the main feature is
the
automated green screen but they also
advertise automatic depth maps
automatic optical flow and other things
so it's not entirely there yet on the
level of a sophisticated video editing
software
but do give it a try if you're
interested you can try it out for free
and get an impression of what's possible
right now
i did it and the auto green screening is
pretty nice
[Music]
next news the mine rl basalt challenge
is now a official nurips 2021
competition
the interesting thing in this challenge
is there is no
reward function but your system is
judged by humans
so the way it works is that you get a
textual description of what you need to
do
for example make a waterfall or build a
village house
and you just let your agent run and then
at the end
a human gets two runs from two different
agents that have tried to perform this
task the human
has to rate which one did it better
there is no
other reward function inherent you may
design one yourself
as a developer in training the system
but ultimately you're only evaluated
on those human judgments since human
judgments
are expensive there is sort of a bit of
a marketplace system in place
with respect to evaluating those things
so in order for your agent to be
evaluated on the platform you first have
to go and evaluate a bunch of other
agents
how exactly this is going to turn out is
not clear yet i can imagine the research
community being good spirits and
actually evaluating
the agents rather than just really fast
click on a random scoring
but we'll see i hope the best for the
challenge and if you're interested
participate so there's an article by
francesco orabona
who recently got tenure and having
gotten tenure apparently
now feels okay to speak out about
some of the problems that plagued the
review system this one is the myth of
the expert
reviewer it is a pretty entertaining
article that
makes the point that if we go more and
more into the direction
of expert evaluation this is not
necessarily
a good thing his main point is that the
more expert you are
the narrower your domain of expertise
and therefore anything falling outside
of that domain you either
don't care about you think it's bad
because it's not in your domain
you think it's bad because it's not done
by you or you just don't know anything
about it because it's
outside of your area of expertise this
delivers a little bit of pushback
that expert reviewers are a good way to
solve the reviewing problem in machine
learning the reviewing problem being
that because of the explosion of the
field we have not enough reviewers and
therefore
more and more non-expert more and more
inexperienced
at the beginning of their careers
researchers come
and review for the big conferences and
generally that signal is very noisy
the author here identifies that with
expert reviewers you get a whole
different set of problems which aren't
necessarily an
improvement to the old system the
article outlines one particular story
where the author
fought really hard to get a paper past
other reviewers simply because the other
reviewers dismissed it and
that was in a system featuring expert
reviewers
he says in reality in my 15 years of
experience i
rarely saw the reviewing system working
as it should
most of the time in order to get a
meaningful decision on a paper
you have to work hard so hard that
people might end up deciding that it is
not worth it i myself have less and less
strength and patience to fight
many of these battles i did not gain
anything in any of them
probably only more enemies so i fully
agree
with this article and with the problems
it outlines so i invite you to
read this article if you want a more
in-depth and an actual example
of how something like this played out a
bit of a silver lining that i
see is that the community seems to be
moving away
from this system of expert reviewers it
would be really sad if we decided that
in addition to the broken review system
we would need to introduce some new on
top review system
featuring expert reviewers from domains
like ethics or something like this
i mean imagine that
so nvidia writes nvidia launches the
uk's
most powerful supercomputer for research
in
ai and healthcare now the comma here
makes me
fairly confident that this is
in fact the most powerful supercomputer
in the uk
and it's applied to research in ai and
healthcare
and it's not just the uk's most powerful
supercomputer for researching
and healthcare whichever way you want to
interpret this this is a big
big machine so apparently nvidia
invested
about a hundred million us dollars and
the computer is for air research as it
seems mainly
in industry research such as medical
research and other things the system is
called
cambridge one and features 80 dgx a100
systems
each of which contains 8 a100 gpus
of course this is all connected with
super fast infinii whatever
and i'm excited to see what people will
make of this beast
it's always cool to see the photo
galleries of these things
i have to say it looks pretty slick but
i can't i can't
help to notice that there is a little
hole in the back there
so this is where your box would go
i guess okay charlie snell
writes an article uh called alien dreams
an emerging art
scene documenting the rise of artists
that make use of
openai's clip model of which they
released at least
a small version i guess into the public
so of course clip is one of the parts of
dali dali is the system that can take
text and turn
it into images now open eye has not
released
dali but just a version of clip however
people have figured out that while it's
not
so easy as with dali you can in fact use
clip which is just sort of a classifier
a judgment day similarity metrics for
images and text you can use it to
generate images
in fact the images it generates look a
lot more
trippy than classic images you get out
of dali
and there is an emerging scene that this
article documents
of what people get out of these models
and it also details a little bit of the
history of how this came about
first using things like big gan which is
also something that i used in my music
video if you haven't seen that yet
[Music]
check it out but then going beyond that
and especially the incorporation of
things like vqgan
have made big differences in this model
and lastly also tricks like the unreal
engine trick
so if you look at these things now they
are really stunning pieces of art
sometimes and they're now not only
images so little videos are made out of
them or they're being combined with
3d photo in painting such that you get a
3d experience of the world that these
models create
i highly invite you to check out this
article and
try the link notebooks for yourself
mit news writes infrared cameras and
artificial intelligence
provide insight into boiling so this
article
is actually about a very serious problem
if you want to cool something using
cooling liquid because the cooling
liquid needs to touch the surface that
it is actually cooling in order to
transport the heat
away from it and there is a thing called
a boiling crisis
where the liquid starts to boil in
between and if that happens to a certain
degree
then the liquid is essentially lifted
off of the surface
which means that the cooling effect
isn't as strong anymore
so too much heat in these systems can
actually lead into a feedback loop
of even more heat and that's what they
refer to as
boiling in this case however
if you just read this as if it were
about like boiling an egg or
boiling your spaghetti it's a much
funnier article
infrared cameras and artificial
intelligence provide insight into
boiling
yes yeah i always wondered how boiling
works
i always thought it's just making stuff
warm but we definitely need ai to
investigate
it says things like in previous research
his team spent
almost five years developing a technique
in which machine learning could
streamline
relevant image processing good job
and other gems such as machine learning
is not
biased by our preconceived hypotheses
about
boiling i'm not so sure about that have
you ever thought that
boiling might be a social construct what
is the data you use
for the boiling who made the data what
color were the eggs that boiled
it also says to collect data they boiled
water
to collect data they boiled water that's
what i would
do too and also this is a big deal
i agree boiling has such complicated
physics
it's been almost impossible despite at
least 50 years of extensive research on
this topic
boiling to develop a predictive model
yeah it's not as easy as if you make
stuff
warm it boils and as an outlook they say
the idea is really to push the button
and come back to the lab once the
experiment has
finished okay i think i've milked that
joke about as far as it can go
next news so forbes writes
language lessons from an artificial
intelligence
so apparently there are companies now
that make use of
image generation in order to assist
language learners which means that
instead of just having some voice talk
to you in the language you want to learn
you do get an avatar with it an ai
generated avatar that can be of any sort
that you want
speak any dialect that you want look any
way you want i guess
they say rendering text into talk is
easy hour one's trick
is to pair that text reading capability
with a friendly human face now while i'm
totally convinced
that a what feels like a personal
interaction might benefit you
in learning a language rather than just
some voice processors
[Music]
yeah that's kind of creepy
well if you if you like things like this
if this is for you
you know good for you you've just gotten
an upgrade to your language learning
skills but you can definitely see the
future
where there's still noticeable artifacts
in the generation of these faces
are just not enough such that you notice
and where the whole appearance
and mannerisms are just a bit more human
honestly i think what most of these
artificial avatar
ai assistant systems get wrong is that
they
always try to model sort of a perfect
human
a absolutely polite and forever
assistive
thing which we all know doesn't exist so
it might be a bit harder to get the
exact calibration right but all of this
might feel a lot more real
if the humans were just kind of stinky
sometimes and
have their own opinion and aren't always
and 100 friendly and polite maybe a
startup idea who knows
and with that that was it from this
week's ml
news and i wish you a pleasant rest of
the week
bye bye
[Music]
you